the daily wire we've been hard at work
keeping our promise we promised you
we're gonna bring you tons of new
content you won't get anywhere else and
that you're going to be excited about so
we said we're getting into the movie
business we are we brought out a movie
last year now we have a brand new movie
that is ready it's ready to go our first
original daily wire production shut-in
it's a seat gripping thriller that will
be available to stream early 2022. the
film is super intense here is what that
trailer sounds like
laney
[Music]
[Applause]
where have you been
going away
i'm going to take off tonight so the
kids can sleep most of the way
well i'm mostly done i just need to
finish cleaning out the pantry
thinking
through the night
please let me out please
lady
[Music]
your daughter she's very pretty don't
you touch my kids
rob
owes me money there's money there's a
lot of money there's thousands of
dollars in the pantry have it all
[Music]
please come on i'm scared
it's a really really intense film man
it's uh
it's a real movie and that's what we do
here at daily wear it has some values
that you're gonna love it is a
terrifying thriller so if you're
planning on adding that terrifying
thriller to your q in 2022
and you want us to keep making content
to combat the over politicized
mainstream entertaining streaming on
major platforms go like and share the
trailer on youtube really your support
makes a huge difference